we're learning another American has died
fighting in Ukraine the U.S Navy
confirmed former Navy SEAL Daniel Swift
was killed during a Russian attack in
eastern Ukraine this week also this week
president zielinski repeated urgent
pleas for allies meeting in Germany
Friday to immediately send Modern tanks
to help Ukrainian forces prepare for
looming Russian attacks Deborah patta
has more from kharkiv
that meeting of Western allies in
Germany did not bring the news that Kev
was hoping for there's still no final
decision on the rapid deployment of
German tanks for Ukraine and the U.S has
signaled that this war is far from over
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff did not mince his words I still
maintain that for this year it would be
very very difficult to militarily eject
the Russian forces from all every inch
of Ukrainian occupied or Russian
occupied Ukraine but General Mark merely
emphasized that with the right weapons
and training Ukraine can still launch a
widespread counter-offensive in Spring
and the U.S will designate the Russian
paramilitary group Wagner as a
transnational criminal organization
releasing satellite images said to show
the group receiving a shipment of Arms
from North Korea
on the Ukrainian Front Line the men of
the bugans Special Forces Brigade
refused to give up hope believing they
can win as long as the West keeps
sending them weapons but for all the
promises of high-tech Firepower there is
no shortcut when it comes to digging in
against the enemy is it difficult to
build trenches when the ground is Frozen
it's very hard major chicken told us
it's rock solid ice with constant rain
and snow
this is trench warfare 14 Sub-Zero
temperatures and there's a lot of
territory to defend this one is just
near the Russian border
the commander and his platoon have been
fighting in the country's East where
Ukrainian soldiers are preparing to
defend against a surge in Russian
attacks
deep below this innocuous looking Pine
Forest is a warrant of fortifications
it's very warm in here where the men
have prepared for the coldest weeks of
winter a Wood-Fired stove warm beds hot
food and drinks it's not so bad chicken
told us but what would really make a
difference are more heavy weapons
that will stop the Bloodshed on the
battlefield sooner president zielinski
said his country needs tanks not
hundreds of thank yous and he told that
meeting in Germany time remains a
Russian weapon and that the waste needs
to speed up the delivery of military aid
for CBS Saturday morning Deborah patter
heart Keith